well we've seen him in castaway fighting
in world war ii and eating boxes of
chocolate it's good that a hanks is in
the news whose name doesn't start with
chat it's a boy chatna coming straight
from the golden globes
apple tv sci-fi post-apocalyptic
adventure directed by miguel sapochnick
the same director of game of thrones
battle of the bastards episode is out
and i'm here to tell you all about the
film's ending what exactly happened to
earth and many interesting facts about
animals
can survive
without water longer than camels
but before we begin make sure to like
and subscribe seriously only 10 of you
are subscribed because here we go meet
finch weinberg our film's protagonist a
guy who spends his days scavenging the
scorched wasteland that is saint louis
missouri although the exact date the
story takes place is unknown we do know
the events of finch take place roughly
15 years after a cataclysmic gamma ray
from the sun pierced the earth's ozone
layer causing the earth to become
extremely hot and unlivable this was
followed by an emt blast which basically
fried every piece of electronics on the
planet without an ozone layer this also
means the added danger of radiation and
to make matters worse finch is dying
it's never explained what exactly he's
dying from but it's implied from the
coughing up of blood and pills that he
takes that it could be from this
radiation you might ask yourself why is
finch all alone and are there other
survivors well it just so happened he
was at work when the explosive gamma ray
hit earth you see finch is an engineer
at tae technology an engineering plant
he's converted into his home and seems
to offer him some protection from the
heat and radiation later in the film
we'll see what happens if he goes out
into the sun unprotected this also
explains the burn scars on his back when
he takes a shower most who survived the
initial gamer ray blast did one of two
things either hid underground or
scavenge and fight amongst each other
for goods finch will later tell his
robot companion that the reason he
scavenges during the day when it's
hottest outside is actually that it's
safer bandits and scavengers roam at
night thus making the day the safer
option and for 15 years finch has
cleared out hundreds of stores and
buildings in the st louis area marking
each building with spray paint but as
you'll see from his map he's running out
of places to scavenge meaning he's also
running out of food to make matters
worse a group of 15 dust storms are set
to converge on his location for a
whopping 40 days and he barely has
enough food for a week so he has to
speed up his plans of moving out west
ahead of schedule this includes
finishing his work on a robot named jeff
my name is jeff one of the things i
liked about jeff's creation was how we
see books from the library being scanned
digitized and uploaded into jeff's
memory these include things like books
about dogs and rvs two things jeff will
need to know if he's to serve his main
function taking care of finch's dog
goodyear when he passes yes his sole
purpose for creating this engineering
marvel is so that his dog will be taken
care of of course only 70ish percent of
his data could be uploaded to him before
they could escape this superstorm so
jeff isn't the smartest or fully
functioning robot around but back to
this adorable dog a dog finch picked off
the dead body of a young girl he chose
not to save while out scavenging years
ago instead of stopping the gunman who
would later kill this child he chose to
hide and not do anything it's one of his
biggest regrets in the movie he calls
himself a coward for not doing anything
hunger turned men into murderers
but me
made me a coward and this leads me to
what i thought was one of the biggest
letdowns of the movie finch's character
arc they set him up as being this loner
coward but we never really see him
overcome that there isn't a big moment
in the film where he gets to redeem
himself this is especially upsetting
considering the film's tragic ending
after overcoming violence and tornadoes
and bandits finch almost makes it to his
final destination the golden gate bridge
why of all places is he heading there at
15 he got a postcard from his absentee
father saying he was going to be there
so he went out and spent all his money
on an expensive suit to make his father
proud but he never heard from him again
so all he really has is this postcard
and perhaps this is why finch is such a
loner it's a protective mechanism if he
never gets close to anyone he can never
get hurt like how his father hurt him
it's kind of sad that he has nowhere
else to go but the place's absentee
father told him to go years ago and
maybe this is why finch has an obsession
with engineering and bridges as seen
with the multiple bridge postcards his
dad was an engineer in the army who
built bridges deep down finch wants to
impress his father so that he'll never
leave the tragic thing is that they'll
never meet not only that finch will
never even make it the place he's always
wanted to visit the golden gate a few
hundred miles away from their final
destination a butterfly smashes into the
window of the rv which is interesting
since there's no way they could live in
this heat this indicates that there's
somewhere where the radiation and heat
is weak and just like that finch is able
to spend his final moments in the sun
without a suit on for the first time in
years this is never really explained in
the movie and i know neil degrasse tyson
but finch earlier mentioned that the
ozone layer was torn apart like a piece
of swiss cheese so it's possible there
are layers of the earth that are
protected and some that aren't the area
around san francisco seems to be
protected as evidenced by finch's dog
being able to survive unfortunately
finch succumbs to his illness before
getting to that bridge jeff creates a
funeral pyre for him and even a
makeshift sign in the end finch's plan
to create a robot to take care of his
only companion was successful hell he
even engineered a can opener into jeff's
body so he could feed the dog but even
though the ending is quite sad there is
a glimmer of hope while navigating the
bridge jeff finds several posters photos
and notes from survivors the lands
surrounding the golden gate bridge shows
signs of life with greenery and flowing
streams this is a chance for a new
beginning so jeff and goodyear venture
off across the bridge symbolic of the
change venturing from one chapter of
their journey to the next even though
this was the end of finches it's just
the beginning for them thanks for
watching everyone remember to like and
subscribe and check out my sci-fi
playlist for more videos and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt until next
time remember
daddy loves you very much